hello and welcome to this video what do
we get no don't Bank oh yeah people
don't want to have it on the bornean so
let's see this is a line which netted me
lots of good positions every Bishop d6
the thing I lost a very painful game
against Duda lodgement then on position
itself was pretty good that I God so
what here and was it castles or was it
be 5 I think it was be five yeah there
was this lucky check on ya I'm take c6
take the 65 Queen edge for check g3
clean before check whoo let's see if i
get that when i was playing hard tonight
after I forgotten about it but let's see
what B is c + V V CMV this is playing
not so clear what why should do here
Knight c3 I'm playing before attacking
the night again in general I mean this
is a very unconventional position why it
has no development whatsoever and pretty
Rick dark squares like III but on the
other hand blacks bishop on CA it looks
weird cannot do much an mp5 out it's a
pretty pretty weird position very
non-standard so yeah Teague's and e5 is
critical he does not play that so now i
can at least castle but i wonder if you
have something else the check is not
doing
all that much then take the five Queen
takes this is this is not good yeah
night c4 is interesting maybe but ok I'm
just canceling that that cannot be bad
really like completely bad now that this
is what is the point yet you want to go
to a formerly he wants to go to a for
not something that looked particularly
desirable to me so if I go Quinn j5 he's
going to play be 6.mp3 the capture only
six is also also on I would definitely
like to take on d5 sometime I wonder
just kun sis seven maybe that's a bit
little bit of a lame move now that the
night only five is really offside it's
okay as c4 is not a good idea
how do i how do I get him to take on to
take on e6 or that I can take on d5 with
him having to take with the pawn this
would be would be great to get in I
can't play night a six potential in
nitra c7 yeah but do you want to play
night huh oh awesome Bishop d7 like
Quincy 7 Bishop d7 he has 85 but I don't
think this is so great after a 59 f 593
is always an issue yeah as I said it's a
pretty difficult position very difficult
to judge because it's so um unusual when
we both have after 10 moves spent like
two minutes and 25 minutes so what is he
up to most them normal looking move
let's say it's probably not to g3 try to
develop the bishop but it's not quite
clear normal is doing doing the job here
and now we can maybe go e 5 huh I should
have thought about that a moment maybe I
can know well okay now i can take this
should be quite quite nice now the d5
pawn going to look somewhat somewhat
isolated so i can go night and sorry
creature a five and then potentially see
form
Master do I want to trade here but then
i can actually I them time taking too
long in 1967 I can play this was
actually quite nice maybe he has not be
294 my yes he has them yes that mmm okay
yeah night between now 97-94 it's
probably okay I'm yeah that's okay for
what but he probably should do that or
maybe you can play with an ID for
somehow like 91 and I think this is a
good choice should you should do this
lets you for now and never take now
Bishop Teague's maybe I can do Bishop a
six I can check first actually this is
this is quite nice I can shake loose i
takes with the pawn okay interesting
interesting didn't have it on the radar
okay first of all i'm going to do this
and limit the limit is night maybe no
maybe i shouldn't've play t6 keep d6
open from my night anyway as I said this
is a tough unconventional position the
queen mime a king position is a little
bit shaky here oh whoa I am
it's a bit shaky my queen esther not
helping here can I somehow queen a 427
yeah this is dangerous what Queen wire
be to can I do this b22 g7 at least
clock clock wise i'm not in such a bad
shape i wonder if you should take on the
ATM mcqueen now is ready to return only
that that looks he wants to go jail for
okay time morning okay let's bring this
back if I can't chapter 8 some stuff I
think I'm fine the general structure is
ok for me is that good kanji five I
don't know that could be weak but the
guy can get to d6 and plain like a
bishop a6k either that I'm happy with
but where do I go ahead go now not to be
six talk to a six
we can go night at 3d too but oh no I
have to cover that check I probably
should have taken the a porn would have
been a bit more helpful check check
quite resides yeah maybe I wasn't
trouble down it looked a little bit it
looked shaky group shaking yeah very
unconventional game coming from this
line under 50 60 64 and b5 yeah
something that I mentioned was this is
this happened to me recently and I'm
against you in harsh and I have forgot
about that I have to check it on h4 yeah
I played something when I was a dead leg
left me upon down night c4 or something
I have to play this one important thing
to remember this is covering this porn
actually and leads to some crazy
complications ok 92mm I want castles
here until NJ for this sort of surprised
me but maybe here it kind of has to do
it he has spent lots of time once this
ridiculous one in half a minute yeah
sometimes what I do is weird anyway
Queen c7 it's not a bad move but there
were many opportunities that can do this
but I wasn't first of all I mean he
can't play this move but I wasn't sure
what happens after that yeah this looks
the
clear to me at all okay Quincy seven
assists not bad we should be seven and
now I got to take here which had like an
accomplishment to me because the pawn is
something that I can maybe a cab and I
don't don't see his places as his pieces
and being placed particularly well at
the same but I mean my pieces also are
weird so now on this and 96 to see 792
and 97 lets you form the other computers
basically at least after a short
calculation agreeing with the both sides
play gives me a slight advantage f5 yeah
I think this is a move that has somehow
have to play in the near future if he
gets to f5 or to you form ok this is
given by the engine that also probably
is ok because I mean now this can be
answered with f5 and I'm winning tempe
Eric goes back i go here it may be
better a little bit these six yeah this
is this is not liked by the computer and
yeah this is true i can i can do the
same i can bring the Queen back this way
and then maybe I am slightly more
comfortable as engine suggest as this
can be attacked with a 926 the new
bishop to a 6 yeah I mean okay it's
basically equal according to the
computer of it it's it's an important
idea here i I didn't are only later
realized when I was played at this
explain that my queen cannot come back
easily and here with Queens would be 6
and this is happening a little bit
quicker yeah this looks dangerous now
with the offside Queen rupiah won the
engine wants to start with this one yeah
I mean little nuances say I can make a
big difference because the question is
can I get this back somehow on time or
not if I'm can hear the engines
evaluation is going up this is not good
now this is not good now this also
introduces the idea of a 3 which is I
think quite important yeah engine 98 m
83 but I just recapture this is good for
white I probably have this is just so
badly placed I mean normally yeah you
would what would assume that this should
be a good yet with the plants night
maybe to c5 and those pieces look stupid
but I'm just losing the ape on here I
mean you can just double on it so that's
not good at all now here white is
seriously bad so Queen d2 was probably
just quicker yeah I'm putting more
pressure on me quicker Bishop c8 yeah
this looks logical and Bishop is
protecting against potential sacrifices
each form and now I try to bring the
Queen around like that now the computer
wants to play would be to be one I kind
of suspected that this might be an idea
I felt like if he does that I wanted to
do this and then come back like this but
he's going he says he has a 3m and
traveling traveling I'm just in trouble
Queen a3 was probably wrong then the
engine wants to take cat and night aight
night to 128 and it looks ridiculous but
this is that it is a good square
actually later to attack the pawn if i
get back here and the not chick made it
i'm ok but i might get checkmate i'm
still don't like this position even
the engine gives gives the white only a
slight edge and the way it turned out
yeah I'm okay i think he is not mating
me anymore my queen is back and cat here
yeah this ending can only be a better
for black tricky is however now i wasn't
sure about Queen to e5 because of the
trade o Queen g5 was actually stronger
okay wow that was really strong via text
this and yes has those ideas Wow now
okay that's that that I completely did
not have on the radar I should play just
a normal move let's aim after somewhat
better porn structure so if anybody is
better it's black but it's probably
still within drawing drawing wage check
check he has to be careful I have this
idea of a textured the pawn is simple
machine some of you went here the fear
goes for this I mean I have I have this
idea but I'm not sure that it is enough
like here
this is winning somehow and i don't know
i have some ways maybe to improve him
like get this here and a 5 and so on you
can do all kinds of things if it wins
not sure how about here i'm just picking
up all the porns yeah interesting game
against be CN v ok guys thanks for
watching